hello welcome to the video playing super
int from India okay let's see what we
get he goes for my Kings Indian style
set up so now that I get this quite
often this night we knew was there not
quite sure what what attracts son or
what what's so attractive for black
about that but I mean it's definitely
play or not saying it's terrible but I
really get it quite often so okay so he
does not have a for something like that
do I go with throw the queenside play I
can put a knight on d5 yeah maybe maybe
do that a 4 and so on looks like it
doesn't do all that much I can take and
go Bishop g5 I thought that would be
somewhat annoying or does he just play
Knight f6 and trade stuff
hmm ok a night before the screen to see
Sarah my cam okay let's do this so we
can trade this now hmm not sure what if
this is actually helping me to be honest
it's difficult out to not do it quite
often this is not such a bad trade
because it tends to expose weaknesses
black king but here it doesn't look all
that great um I wanted to actually take
and player 4 but d3 is hanging yeah I
think I still have to do that to be
honest otherwise it doesn't make any
sense what I did I mean c6 is also
hanging maybe this is maybe this has
some some technical issues but should be
three bishops in 6b should be one we
should a8 yam but I don't really have a
Heather's decent alternative him
he moves the rock Bishop g5 should be ok
I think something special for black so
now I cannot take five and this is
hanging so check this is probably
correct and now like to move the night
of course but not not happening yeah
look afterwards it's not threatening to
take on e5 which I really would like to
do like to threaten
yeah it still feels like probably the
best move this one okay
hmm
Jim it's a little bit cramped this
pollution is cramped Quincy three or
something would be good but is good III
coming
hmm yeah anyway I don't know it's a bit
uncomfortable
you through i'll take out six and then
up g tool mmm not nice
can also maybe just take it now it looks
very shaky I don't quite see a win for
black but I wouldn't be surprised if
there is one
hmm coming up 43
I didn't even see that
Roman god
hmm yeah so that 95 Bishop c5 didn't
tend to work out well
yeah I think he probably should move the
bishop not take it not one hundred
percent sure about this but it can move
that lets say to f7 do I have something
goodnight b5 I thought booty Ezra PA Wow
time warnings out out for the fancy
stuff
Mary Bishop g5 is impossible and always
playing the technically more technically
motivated moves
check
okay three is good you can also take a
tune really can't do all that much am
check check it's too bad unfortunately
check
check check check check check white
forfeits on time yeah that wasn't a good
plan i guess yeah we had a fairly normal
looking position some somewhere around
here probably this 95 Bishop g5 isn't
isn't all that good hmm computer lights
f4 yeah anyway this wasn't good young
didn't work out as I had a thought check
it's probably not like losing but it
leads to problems engine still like that
for able to check how bad this is it
probably is somewhat bad jacket it's
also kind of awkward to claim h4 given
by the computer and this is not very
human yeah this is leading into problems
after e3 which you didn't blame here
some somewhat okay vit
not really not really that it's just
about a good position III move it's just
not good the pond is just really really
dangerous that seems that if I go kingi
to at least that's knowing there's no
immediate disaster but it looks wrong it
really looks wrong for white this this
construction is quite dangerous even
though the engine gives acquired don't
quite like it and I default very fancy
but but strong push up to five again
strong check yeah no it's just not
possible to save it check too many pawns
simply yeah just want to check it was
what's this engine thing at 4am
I just make some sense um I mean this
this looks kind of nice actually and if
you take CA I've got my eggs which is
this is really annoying notice that this
under attack I'm threatening to take e
6f 5 lb seven so that's really not good
interesting ng wants to play a six with
roughly equal play that's definitely
better than what I did now now that that
didn't that the only good idea with
Bishop g5 ok glass thanks for watching